[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et un plaisir de vous
retrouver pour ce numéro spécial de mode
d'emploi entièrement consacré à
l'entreprise éphémère de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines tout de suite
le sommaire c'est une première sur le
territoire l'ouverture d'une entreprise
éphémère ce concept permet à 50
demandeurs d'emploi d'oeuvrer ensemble
pour trouver à chacun un emploi
accompagnés par des coquilles s'organise
en service pour répertorier les offres
sur le territoire nous les avons suivis
durant cette aventure de cette semaine
l'heure est au bilan l'entreprise
éphémère myriade de saint quentin en
yvelines vient de fermer ses portes ce
vendredi 26 avril
ils viennent de quitter leur poste et
sont déjà sur notre plateau pour
débriefer de cette expérience nous
recevons trois associés train trois
associés pardon accompagnés de leur
coach et ils sont là parmi nous bonsoir
à tous
donc il ya nolwenn vous avez trente ans
vous est juriste en droit public et vous
habitez montigny le bretonneux etienne
rutte 43 ans consultant en
responsabilité sociétale pour les
entreprises mirabel perron 36 ans vous
vous êtes d'elancourt vous avez une
expérience en télé opération et vous
avez conçu vous êtes vous avez participé
à l'entreprise éphémère en tant que
attachés administratifs c'est çà et là
coach amira ouahrani donc ça fait depuis
plusieurs années que vous ouvrez pour
l'entreprise éphémère partout en france
bonsoir à vous quatre merci d'être sur
notre plateau et on va commencer avec
vous avant de revoir ces images amiral
rani sur l'origine de l'entreprise
éphémère comme ans est née cette ce
concept en fait et comment ça s'est
installé sur saint quentin en yvelines
alors c'est un concept qui a été créé
par deux fondateurs qui sont ces nids
garance et didier krief l'aventuré a
démarré à arles
et puis par la suite les deux ont voulu
développer leur concept au niveau
national et pour cela c'est c'est une
rencontre avec deux personnes de bpi
group le cabinet de conseil rh donc
sandrine jean st nicolas mariot qui ont
permis vraiment de développer ce concept
au niveau national et pour 51 en
yvelines donc un très beau soutien de la
communauté d'agglo et puis d'autres
partenaires et
il évoquera peut-être un peu après on y
reviendra oui sur saint quentin en
yvelines qui vous a fourni notamment les
locaux qui vont aussi la communication
auprès des demandeurs d'emploi du
territoire et puis pôle emploi aussi
appeler pôle emploi qui est un
partenaire privilégié alors donc elle a
été lancée le 12 mars dernier
l'entreprise éphémère de saint quentin
en yvelines
ils sont une cinquantaine de demandeurs
d'emploi avoir rejoint cette structure
objectif répertorier les offres de
travail sur le territoire et s'exercer
dans un seul but trouver un emploi
retour sur ces sept semaines regarder
pendant cette semaine ils sont devenus
associés de l'entreprise éphémère
myriade une cinquantaine de demandeurs
d'emploi ont intégré cette société son
activité rechercher les offres d'emploi
dans le bassin économique du territoire
une organisation autour de six services
est accompagné par trois coachs pour
chaque service il ya un coach un coach
qui va les travées qui va coordonner
l'ensemble du service et donc on va
confier des missions personnes on va
vraiment ciblées en fonction de
l'appétence et des compétences parmi ses
missions le service face à face à sur la
prospection directement auprès des
entreprises
ça c'est une carte qui a été déployée en
fait par notre service face à face afin
qu'ils puissent repérer le territoire
sur lequel ils vont prospecter et en
fait ils indiquent par un stabilo taz
les zones qu'ils ont déjà effectué ou
qui sont en cours de prospection
ce jour-là farid et lilia accompagnés
par leur coach krystel sont sur la zone
commerciale de chambourcy une
prospection notamment chez des
concessionnaires automobiles convient de
l'entreprise éphémère mais ryad pour les
amateurs de talent et notre démarche
c'est donner 50 associés installé sur le
secteur de saint quentin en yvelines et
nous venons voir les entreprises du
secteur pour savoir si vous avez des
besoins de personnel commercialisation
de véhicules ateliers d'entretien et de
réparation les activités de cette
société avec des besoins en main
d'oeuvre
moi je trouve que c'est un très bon
concept parce que ça permet aux
personnes va être dans une démarche
active et puis et puis du coup garder le
pied à l'étrier et développer des
compétences au niveau commercial
les deux associés repartent de cette
entreprise avec deux offres d'emploi au
total le service face à face à
rencontrer plus d'une centaine de
sociétés sur tout le territoire
j'ai une équipe extraordinaire
qui ont le bon discours et qui sont très
très bien la démarche qui soit un très
bon accueil dans les entreprises pour
moi le bilan et il est très très positif
parce qu'on avait une grosse grosse
équipe de face à face qui vraiment est
sorti tous les jours en binôme sur les
différentes activités et on fait
vraiment tout aux entreprises qu'on va
rencontrer tous soient un commerce un
petit un grand une pme on privilégie
quand même une entreprise il ya un accès
direct qui facile comme une pme ou un
petit commerce
les grands groupes en général on a plus
de difficultés à notre niveau donc on
passe par un service en interne la
prospection auprès des grands groupes
c'est notamment la mission d'isabelle ce
matin là au bout de la ligne un
représentant de safran résultat elle
obtient le contact d'un collaborateur
des ressources humaines je suis chargé
en fait d'aller chercher des drh des
grandes entreprises sur le bassin de
saint quentin en yvelines entre autres
et de les faire venir de nombreux
représentants d'entreprises ont fait le
déplacement à travers des réunions
appelé open job ils viennent proposer
des offres d'emploi c'est notamment le
cas de la sncf
j'ai des offres de d'aiguilleur non
qu'opérateur et ensuite des offres de
technicien supérieur au niveau bac + 2 à
bac + 3 pour travailler dans les postes
d'aiguillage assurer la sécurité des
circulations et la régularité des trains
au total des associés ont répertorié
près de 650 offres d'emplois
l'entreprise éphémère l'occasion aussi
de s'entraîner pour trouver un emploi
entretien d'embauché fictif pour etienne
et laurence deux associés de
l'entreprise éphémère myriade de saint
quentin en yvelines
amira where any la coach observe pour
les conseiller sur les points à
améliorer
voilà une activité quotidienne pour les
membres de l'entreprise éphémère une
personne va jouer le rôle du candidat ou
là il va s'entraîner en faisant son
pitch et faire sa simulation
d'entretiens avec des questions qui lui
sont posées
après il ya une personne qui va jouer le
rôle du recruteur est comme ça il va
donc lui lance et l'entretien de
recrutement et poser les questions
c'est un très bon exercice pour moi
d'être du côté recruteur avec une des
coachs et de pouvoir aider mes mais mes
collègues à se positionner sur sur leur
poste et à voir ce qui va ce qui va
moins bien et étendre avec des axes
d'amélioration pour les aider etienne
lui joue le rôle du candidat
dans quelques jours il a un entretien
d'embauché dans une entreprise à
guyancourt
à la fin de l'expérience onze membres de
l'entreprise éphémère ont retrouvé un
emploi
seize sont dans un processus de
recrutement et ont mis à jour les
chiffres donc c'est 15 associés qui ont
retrouvé un emploi oui puisque il y en a
qui ont signé aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est
ça
donc je me tourne d'abord vers vos
etienne brut
on vous a vu dans le sujet vous
prépariez des entretiens alors comment
se sont passées ces entretiens réel
parce que la ct fictifs et réels comment
ça s'est passé
effectivement quelques jours après le
tournage j'étais en entretien dont j'ai
eu un premier entretien il ya une
dizaine de jours
qui s'est très bien passé avec deux
dirigeants de l'entreprise ils m'ont
donné un délai de 15 jours pour me
recontacter ce qu'il allait en être par
la suite
trente minutes plus tard je recevais un
email pour me dire que j'étais invité à
passer la seconde entretien qui a eu
lieu la semaine dernière et donc là vous
êtes en attente d'une réponse mais ça a
l'air plutôt positive
plus en tout cas c'est très bien engagée
j'ai même eu un rappel hier on m'a
demandé deux contacts professionnels
qu'ils vont contacter pour la poursuivre
encore cette démarche de retenue
mirabel perron vous êtes l'une des
quinze associé à avoir retrouvé un
emploi grâce à l'entreprise éphémère est
ce que vous pouvez nous raconter cette
embauche bah c'est suite à un ou deux
jeunes donc l'entreprise project est
venu se présentait donc un open jeunes
organisé par l'entreprise
donc suite à cette présentation ben j'ai
déposé mon cv j'ai eu ça m'a permis de
rencontrer directement et donc c'est
pour un poste quoi projet texte et une
autre au gré des dessinateurs projeteurs
d'accord c'est quelque chose que vous
attendiez à savoir au début c'était pas
mon projet professionnel du départ
donc ça m'a permis de m'ouvrir des
portes à certains métiers auxquels je
n'aurais pas pensé parce que c'était
peut-être pas accessible à ce type de
diplôme enfin au diplôme que j'avais
c'est le bilan que vous faites de votre
expérience vous dans l'entreprise
éphémère oui un bilan très positif pour
moi pour ma part nolwenn douchez vous
avez trente ans alors on vous voit vous
vous accueillez les représentants
d'entreprises
vous êtes l'image en fait de
l'entreprise éphémère de saint quentin
en yvelines dans quelques heures si une
partie de l'image puisque on était quand
même tous représentants de la société de
l'autre reprise éphémère en fait on est
tous associés donc sur un pied d'égalité
notamment aussi avec les coachs et donc
oui c'est vrai que c'est moi qui ai
beaucoup accueilli que ce soit les
entreprises ont qui venaient en open job
comme a dit
mirabel et les institutionnels qui sont
venus nous rendre visite tels que des
représentants de pôle emploi de la
communauté d'agglomération aussi faim
voilà c'est grâce à l'entreprise
éphémère que vous avez pris se dissout
son côté communication ouverture vers
les autres
ou c'est quelque chose qui était déjà en
voie avant alors j'avais déjà un petit
peu ça en moi puisque dans les
différentes expériences professionnelles
que j'ai eus j'ai fait un peu d'accueil
et notamment dans les services publics
donc j'ai vu vraiment des publics très
différents mais là disons que ça m'a
permis d'avoir plus confiance
d'oser des choses voilà alors on va voir
des images versa c'est le dernier jour
on vous qu'on voit à l'image mais on va
voir des images du premier jour on va
voir que vous faisiez connaissances vous
étiez en groupe vraiment vous commenciez
à vous organiser c'est le jour où vous
avez décidé même du nom myriade dans
quel état d'esprit vous étiez à ce
moment là et comment vous êtes
aujourd'hui finalement comment ça vous a
transformé cette expérience qui va
commencer sur cette question
étienne potable on y va alors la
transformation elle a été à deux en deux
temps la première fois la découverte de
l'équipe et puis d'essayer de déterminer
où est ce que je pourrais une place pour
être utile pour le groupe est aussi pour
moi puisque c'est l'un des challenge de
de l'entreprise est fait mais on est là
pour trouver un job pour les autres mais
aussi pour soi bien sûr et puis le
deuxième temps c'était de me
perfectionner et d'aider les autres à se
perfectionner sur leur présentation en
trois minutes et sur la conduite des
entretiens d'embauché fait le côté
collectif ou qui exactement
non la loi ben c'est aussi cette idée du
collectif en fait qui m'a beaucoup
intéressé interpellés non dans
l'expérience de l'entreprise éphémère
wii 2 voilà de rencontrer des personnes
très différentes et qui veut nous
apporte en fait celle échanges voilà qui
apporte beaucoup
ou alors vous vous êtes en cours de
processeur plus petit fille voilà j'ai
des candidatures qui sont en cours
j'attends j'attends les retours donc
voilà les vrais mirabel alors vous avez
un emploi
comment ça vous a transformé aussi est
ce que vous sentez différentes de
par rapport au 12 mars oui parce qu'il
ya eu beaucoup d'échangés avaient des
profils très différents donc ça a
apporté beaucoup humainement
donc ça a permis aussi de sortir un
petit peu de l'isolément qu'on peut
ressentir quand on est seul face à aux
marchés dans quoi à la maison donc là on
a mis en commun nos compétences certains
nous ont fait des petites formations
nous ont apporté des conseils etienne
m'a fait un entretien donc ils m'avaient
préparé donc ait eu richard aussi un des
coaches qui nous ont vraiment mis en
condition donc très positif on voit
amira vous allez qu'on veut on arrive
bientôt au terme de cette émission on va
conclure avec vous on voit c'est plutôt
positif qu est ce que vous vous retenez
à la fois globalement de cette
expérience parce que ils sont trois
aujourd'hui en plateau mais c'était une
cinquantaine au sein de l'entreprise a
créé nord de saint quentin en yvelines
globalement et aussi sur chacun d'entre
eux moi je trouve que globalement et
enfin de manière générale pour les 50
associés qu'on avait au démarrage c'est
finalement des personnes qui ont
énormément évolué entre le démarrage de
laventure des personnes qui sont plutôt
introverti ou qui n'osait pas trop des
pertes de confiance et finalement
progressivement et au fur et à mesure de
l'aventuré
ce sont des personnes en fait c'est pour
moi elles ont éclos elles ont grandi
elles ont repris confiance en elle voilà
l'estiment de soi
la confiance en soi et puis le job donc
pour une belle partie d'entre eux ce
sera le mot de la fin peut-être vous
allez revenir parce que les élus de
saint quentin veut trouver positif cette
expérience est que vous allez revenir
avec grand plaisir si on nous accueille
les bras ouverts comme on l'a fait
jusqu'à présent
je vous remercie à tous les cas train
d'être venu sur notre plateau et merci à
vous de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
le mois prochain pour un nouveau numéro
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]